It
doesn't matter if you're still alive Lilia What the hell you really don't remember me
But if that's the case then it can't be helped
Okay then please marry
me What are you talking about Hi  Just say that
, I promise you a comfortable life and a happy future
.
I'm Eileen Lauren
Rotarish I'm
your fiancé Claude-sama Are you Airi?  I do
n't want to let the Lilias who have been a burden on the people or helped them go through a hard time
Please
accept the enthusiasm of the engagement and listen to the
[music]
I cut it off, but
I love you.
Well then, go home early
I'm a nuisance too We
're just as kind
, aren't we?
I want to bring it back right away,
so please stop doing that. It's
fun.